dangerous new front in ukraine alarming
signs of an escalation in that conflict
as russian missiles hit a ukrainian
military base near the border with
poland killing at least 35 people
the base is just 15 miles from nato
territory where american troops are
located a russian airstrike also struck
a residential building in the capital
city of kiev at least two people dead
there according to a ukrainian official
we have full team coverage including
norah o'donnell in poland and we're
going to begin with charlie dagetta in
keeve charlie good morning we mentioned
the bad news but there are some signs of
hope this morning what are they
good morning tony yes peace talks have
restarted today and both sides say there
has been substantial progress at the
very least ukraine is hoping for a
temporary ceasefire to evacuate
civilians from the hardest hit areas
the massive airstrike on ukraine's
military base right on poland's doorstep
has drawn the us and nato allies closer
to this conflict a base used by american
and nato forces to train ukrainian
troops the message from moscow could not
be clearer
the smile of ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky trying to boost the
spirits of the wounded disappeared in a
stark warning overnight
i repeat again if you do not close our
skies it is only a matter of time before
russian missiles fall on your territory
he said on the territory of nato and on
the homes of citizens of nato countries
the red cross says time is running out
for hundreds of thousands of residents
in the besieged city of mariopol where
government officials say at least
2500 people have died
including we have learned this morning
this mother and her unborn baby wounded
in last week's air raid strike on the
maternity hospital
a woman in a kiev suburb plays one last
song before she leaves her bomb damaged
home
[Music]
in urban just northwest of the capital
soldiers carry away the wounded and the
dead
where residential neighborhoods have
come under heavy bombardment for days a
child skips along despite the danger all
around
those who do manage to escape amid the
shelling and sniper fire flee here to a
neighboring village
you can see what it's come down to for
the people who don't have vehicles
who have fled from these villages just
in the back of these
cargo trucks
they're being handed warm drinks and
some water and something to eat
at least they're safe
for now neighbors who have stayed behind
to help knowing full well they're right
on the path of russia's merciless
advance toward the capitol
and begging to be heard eliana told us
close our skies so our kids can sleep
slowly so the whole country can live
aliona is an english teacher with two
small children
they must be so scared what do you tell
them yeah
actually we try to to to explain them
that
we have the greatest army you know and
and they will protect us and will defend
us and they believe us
are you going to stay here no matter
what yes yes yes and me and my family
and my children
the u.n has estimated 2.7 million people
have fled the country that doesn't
include the hundreds of thousands of
displaced residents like those who
narrowly escape fighting in search of
safer parts inside the country
vlad
charlie dagged in key for us thank you
charlie